et voici maintenant quelqu'un qui manque
complètement de toupet pourtant c'est un
maître ès provocations
le professeur chan
est-ce provocation maître ès
provocations tu veux je m habite dans le
champagne pas encore à la fin tout à
l'heure
alors deux mois
j'aimerais que tu ton certificat
d'études en 11 ans oui c'est
exceptionnel époque c'était 14 mois
s'étaient 14 et j'ai eu une dispense et
c'était à l'époque du marché le pétain
et le maréchal pétain a envoyé une
lettre de félicitations mon cher enfant
je vous félicite d'avoir réussi et tout
ça toi et donc à partir de ce moment là
j'ai chanté je sais moi qui ai écrit la
chanson maréchal nous voilà c'est toi
vrai talent utile chez nous voilà enfin
la dette atteint 10 mois alors à 15 ans
tu es parti faire le tour de france à 15
ans devant les beaucoup de jouer à 15
ans tu découvres la branlette
c'est vrai tu sais tu as été tout petits
à l'école la petite kate qui l'album que
la voix monte tout doucement et moi
j'étais entouré de petites soeurs trente
deux petites fentes qui sentait bon
l'ammoniac
c'est vrai du macasty visé quand
l'histoire de france à 15 ans c'est tour
de france et a vite fait ouais c'est
petit la france est un village c'est
comme si tu traverse une rue qui va la
grande rue dans la petite rue l'hexagone
et puis après je me suis dit tiens je
m'engage pour la loge il s'était engagé
pour la gauche il y ait ce qui m'a plu
dans l'indochine c'est que y'a une pas
d'appeler c'est vrai pas de gendarmes il
ya des mecs du contingent il y avait que
des voyous on tenait un l'indochine
c'était quatre fois la france et on
tenait sa avec 20,10 le voyou à l'époque
française après les américains il faut
ils ont fui un millier liot de gros
crude américain
nous on est nuls à deux chiffres avec
quelques années avec grabeel voyous en
55 qui rencontrent kavanagh nom jean
d'alos chine
jacques dans un hôpital militaire
tuberculeuse 100% insauvable tchèque la
tuberculose site un poumon atteint
entendant les vins mais moi j'avais les
deux ouais qu'est ce qu'on fait mais je
me suis évadé l'hôpital
comme j'ai guéri j'étais condamné la
terreur bien lorsque tu filmes tout le
temps été données ou mange monsieur gary
avec l'alcool j'ai un grand hommage à
faire aujourd'hui je profite de ton
émission d'ardisson parce que il n'ya
pas beaucoup d'émissions comme l'a dit
est vrai 1
si allah mais elles sont pas pareil que
les ce que je dis rien mais j'ai un
grand et un grand hommage à rendre à
l'alcool et au tabac sans l'alcool et le
tabac je ne serais pas là je serais moi
c'est l'alcool le tabac est même
peut-être la veyron qui va sauver jean
baucou hommage dans la vérole tout ça à
tous ces petits virus a touché dans ces
petites fantaisies conseil constate un
et tous les gros cons titi qui me
supprime sa qui balançaient travaux loup
du bois de boulogne
me rendais compte c'est beau travelo du
bois de boulogne comme il était beau à
paris on n'est pas voir le trône âme ses
gargouilles tous la gueule comme ça et
qui ne suce même pas en 1960 du fond de
grille
c'est un accident ouais je rencontre
kavanagh je vendais des jours la rue tu
vois je rencontre kavanagh reiser fred
topor machin et il me disait chant
qu'est-ce que tu prends la hat ont pas
qu'elle joue son droit à bien avec nous
tu vas nous tu vas être d'autres
éditeurs et puis j'étais l'éditeur alors
il ya eu donc bal tragique à colombey le
journal était bien lancée les lundis
soirs eu des trois ports sont devenus
des rendez-vous obligé de tous les
dessinateurs et guinée et des groupies
et des groupes et sa tirade est cool
alors explique moi comment ça se passe
et les fera porte à la barre eu des
trois potes c'est à la fin du journal
ont donc ont bouclé hier offres ont
bouché vraiment les trous ouais et du
journal et des groupies qui est venu
nous voir
je me souviens d'une anecdote je peux te
raconter l'absolu recueillir tout ce que
tu veux
j'ai un copain je peux pas dire le nom
c'est un grand dessinateur de charlie
hebdo et il était et avait une grosse
[ __ ] pas dire il avait une grosse [ __ ]
il avait une copine et une copine qui
faisait du porno au théâtre signé g pour
tenir pourtant et je ferme le bureau
tout le monde était parti souffre elle
et moi
et puis elle ne prend à part il me dit
chan est ce que je peux te demander
anciens
10 juillet ma chérie comme tu veux et
puis à midi cgem je dit pas son nom
il est marié les enfants bilingues trop
grosse [ __ ]
est ce que tu pourrais m'en culé ce soir
je suis dit ma chérie moi j'ai une [ __ ]
normal
ce sera un plaisir pour moi c'est les
anecdotes du bouclage de charles denner
sa une que j'ai retenue franchement son
service explique alors pour le moment en
dehors de tes mémoires tu fais un
journal pour les enfants de 4 à 7 ans
qui s'appelle gros dada on a un gros
dada voilà alors parle-nous de gros dada
ça c'est ma nouvelle passion
alors tous les tous les lecteurs qui ne
connaissent il dit au chaud - de koné
est à pacifier ta vie a fait rire les
gros cons maintenant différés lé petit
con way
les gosses en raffolent et couche avec
le les gosses vous leur payer gros d'aï
couche avec les petites filles se
branler et tout y couche avec ça y est
cros dada c'est la drôle d'idée petit
vivant dont je suis le fils de satan
je sais que papa montant